foreign
[Music]
let's get started
this is
aiml302 unlocking Innovative AI use
cases with text and multimodal
embeddings
my name is Anand I'm a group product
manager in the Google Cloud vertex AI
platform and I'm really glad to be
joined on stage by my colleague Fabian
also a product manager in the vertex AI
platform
and Eric CTO of innovative company
vervin Verve is a Google Cloud customer
let's do a quick rundown of the agenda
before we dive in I'll start with a
quick overview of what are embeddings
then I'll pass things over to Fabian to
do a cool demo with multimodal
embeddings then Eric will talk about
Verve and how they power Innovative and
differentiated experiences for their
customers with embeddings after that
we'll do some architectural patterns
talk about embedding tuning and then
it's q a
for Q a we have a mic in the center of
the room so if you have a question uh
we'd request you to walk over to the mic
so that everyone can listen to your
question
all right so with that let's let's dive
in so what are embeddings
I call them The Unsung workhorses of
contemporary AI you're not going to hear
much about embeddings in the news
but today some of the most widespread
and commercially important applications
of AI are powered by embeddings you're
probably thinking hey man enough with
the marketing Spiel what are embeddings
really
well embeddings are a AI model generated
encoding of content as a vector or array
of numerical floating Point values
typically the content that is encoded as
embeddings is unstructured contents you
have text or images and so forth but it
can actually be any type of content
now a good
good embedding generating model will
encode Rich semantic information about
the content in the embedding vector so
let's take as an example the vertex AI
text embeddings API it takes text as
input and it will return an embedding
Vector of dimensionality
768. so what that means is the embedding
Vector that you get back has 768
numerical floating Point values
now 768 floating Point values may not
sound like much it's just 768 numbers
but the breadth and depth of semantic
information that is captured by that
embedding Vector nuanced semantic
information is incredible
so embeddings are a very powerful and
versatile tool and they're used in many
creative ways often they're used as
inputs to other Downstream AI models
today I want to touch upon the property
that is by far the most popularly
leveraged property of embeddings
so as I mentioned embeddings encode Rich
semantic information about the content
right so if you have two pieces of
content that have that are semantically
similar then their embedding vectors
should be similar
so if I computed a distance measure
between the embeddings then the
embeddings of semantically similar items
should be close to each other and the
embeddings of items that are
semantically dissimilar should be far
apart and this property is by far the
most popularly leveraged property of
embeddings so let's actually take a look
at this example image here so we have
embeddings created from books so we took
the textual content of books produced
embeddings and then the embeddings are
projected onto a two-dimensional space
and that's the image you're looking at
over there and what we find is the
embeddings for books that belong to the
same genre they're typically cluster
together
of this property of embeddings powers
many many compelling applications and
I'll pass things over to Fabian actually
demo one such cool application
right thank you Anand
um thank you hi everyone and thank you
for joining us in person this year in
San Francisco
so as Anan mentions embeddings can be
used to support a variety of use case
and today I'm delighted to show you how
embeddings can be used to create a
blazing fast multimodal product search
experience
and for that
um we build a demo we've built a demo in
partnership with Mercury Mecca is a
Japanese e-commerce company connecting
millions of people to shop and sell and
sell items on their Marketplace so let's
Dive In
okay we'll start with the text based
semantic product search on the Mercury
Marketplace
so one thing for this demo we only used
product image provided by Mercury as
input and nothing else no the emails are
not tagged there is no product
description anything like that
okay so here I'm searching for
a stylish desk
made out of metal
so you can see here that product search
is happening on the Fly and returns
results really quickly
so here we're matching the embeddings of
the text query
with the embeddings of the all the
indexed product image and I'm adding the
product to my to my cart
all right so now let's try a more
complex query
so here I'm looking for a video game
that I just can't remember the name of
it so here's the query a Nintendo switch
okay as a console video game
we're narrowing down a video game with a
red climber as the main character you
may know who's that guy
here we go Super Mario 3D World that's
the one I'm looking for so
um here again we're only using product
image and and here that image embeddings
the user query with relevant results
and that kind of
um semantic search would be very
difficult to properly handle with a
conventional approach with you know
keyword bass for example
okay third example
um this is an image based product search
so here all I have is an image of a
product that I would like to find on the
macri marketplace think about you know
Google Lens right
so here all I need to do is take the
photo upload the photo I I I'm of the
product I'm looking for in that case I
snapped the photo again it's a Nintendo
switch Cardinals game for Zelda breath
of the wild great game by the way
and here I can see multiple options
right so I'm picking that one as a
master Edition Perfect all right add to
the card so here we've been matching the
embeddings of the input image with all
the embeddings of the of the product
image and now I think I've got hundreds
of hours of fun gameplay in front of me
okay
so what makes the demo so unique well
it's fast right
um you get search results within
milliseconds right in the backhand
milliseconds to do matching while
retaining a deep semantic understanding
two it scales very well for this demo we
used 5.7 million product image that's a
lot but that architecture that
architecture can scale out to billions
of products while maintaining the same
blazing fast response time and
throughput as well
and third ah my favorite it's easy right
so here there is no data labeling
involved model training
um just bring in your data and the
vertex CI embeddings API and Vector
search will do the work for you
so before the Deep dive into the
architectural patterns that we've been
using behind with for that demo I would
like to introduce Eric puff Eric is very
CTO and Verve has been pioneering the
use of vertex imbeddings and Eric will
tell us more about their Journey thank
you very much
excited to be here my name is Eric Poff
with Verve we're a video powered
feedback platform the name stands for a
combination of video plus survey equals
Verve
and our goal is to improve the world of
customer feedback because
if you got there and look
um
there's uh
a lot if you go out there and look for
Content reviews and ratings there's a
lot of problems out there with that
world how can you trust the data a lot
of it's Anonymous and if you're a brand
or company how can you make decisions
based on that information so with video
feedback
we introduced the human element into the
process
after all that information make it
authentic right and now as a brand you
have data you can trust so that you can
make improvements to your products or
services
our opportunity then at Verve is how do
we make sense of all this data
that's where embeddings come in we embed
everything and let me walk through a
quick example
uh let's say you're a shoe company
and you want to you have a new idea for
a concept and you want to get feedback
on it test it out
we'll start with your customers
what are their likes what are their
dislikes
um what are they talked about in the
past well embed all of that
put that into a model
um and then cluster it and then we'll
find the segmentations so this example
we have a segment down there in the
bottom left we'll launch a Verve to them
collect their feedback embed all the
information that they provided and then
we can produce results from that so we
can tailor those results to if you're a
product designer you're in research or
you're in marketing
all that stuff is powered by embeddings
I won't spend a lot of time on this but
I figured I'd show you how easy it is to
get uh to get going so if if you have
ideas on how do I get started and I want
to use embeddings here's what we did we
had an existing data flow where we had
our data we transcribed it from the
videos and then we introduced an
embedding step where we'll embed that
text
then we'll index it into a vector
database
and then when we see we'll use that
database to train our models as well
observe uh serve all the insights into
our application as well so let me show
you some real world examples
um I kind of want to stress this out
that this is this stuff is live right
now in our application uh we're super
proud about it the first one is like
object detection
so we've asked people to hey what's your
favorite shoe uh tell us what you like
about it
we can then take that video strip it out
into text take the video portion of it
get the frames we can then identify the
objects in it and then do some some what
we call Smart objects and smart
detection right this provides a lot of
value back to our customers so that I
can now pick out what people are talking
about and do object identification
the next one we call magic wheels so if
you imagine we have hundreds and
thousands of these campaigns out there
at any one time and we're collecting
hundreds and hours of video no one wants
to sit and go through all that video
uh but with the power of embeddings we
can take that information and find out
what are the highlights so we have a
highlighting model all built on
embeddings and we can tease all that
information out and create like a four
to five minute highlight meal and we can
also find the topics uh for each one as
well so topic modeling keywords top
phrases and we can create highlight
reels for all those as well
and then last but not least is our uh we
can summarize the data we can do
recommendations we can also generate new
ideas right so drag the retrieval
augmented generation uh kind of
philosophy and framework which I believe
we'll be talking about a little bit we
use that as well it's all powered by
embeddings so we can take that
information generate summaries we can
come up with recommendations where to go
to next and then also generate ideas hey
this to solve this problem or pain point
that consumers talked about do this so
we feed all that into the llm and get
that information back and at the end of
it we have what we call our brand AI
all powered by embeddings so I'll hand
it back to Fabian and talk about the
architectural patterns
thank you very much Eric
um this is really exciting to see how
verbe is using Ai and embeddings to
extract novel insights from unstructured
data
so now let's explore the architectural
patterns that are commonly used to put
embeddings to work
okay
to achieve embedding similarity in
production at scale we rely on two key
enablers one the vertex CI embeddings
API to generate embeddings and to the
vertex I Vector search to appear from
fast and scalable embedding similarity
search
okay let's have a closer look at the
first key enabler generating embeddings
so to get an embedding all you need to
do is take your content send your
content
text image both to an embedding API
endpoint
the response will contain an embedding
which is a vector representation with
with a deep semantic information of the
encoded content that you can use in your
Downstream tasks
and today Google Cloud offers two type
of embeddings
and multimodal so which one to choose
okay if your goal is to create high
quality text embeddings that you can use
for text classification question
answering for example text embedding is
the right choice so this embedding
supports long form document as an input
and generate embeddings in a 768
dimensional vector
if your use case involves image or pairs
of text image multi-model embedding is
the one you want to pick multi-model
takes image or text or both as an input
and output a 1408 dimensional vector
okay the second key enabler is Vector
search
so Vector search is used by Google
actually internally with a search play
YouTube
and many more to provide fast and
relevant search results as well as
recommendation
so the challenge or the problem with
Vector search is very simple it's how do
I find similar embeddings really really
fast
I would have seen earlier embeddings and
embedding is a vector right and and
similarity search can be done by
calculating the distance between between
those those two vectors so small
distance suggests High similarity and um
and large distance suggest low
similarity so it's pretty
straightforward it's pretty basic math
here but it's not easy when you have to
deal with millions or billions of
embeddings right so you can try to you
know just brute force it right but for
an example with the macro demo five
let's say five million product at you
know 1408 you know embedding Dimension
you need to repeat the calculation seven
billion times right so that's going to
work right but it's going to take a very
long time to finish and not provide the
best user experience to say the least
so how can we solve for that
well researchers have been studying a
technique called a-n-n approximate
nearest neighbor and a n uses Vector
quantization to separate the embedding
space into multiple clusters with a tree
structure and that involves a fast and
scalable search and a few years ago
Google research published a new a n
algorithm called scan s-c-a-n-n
scan is considered as one of the best a
n algorithm in the in the industry and
today Google Cloud developers so all of
you can take the full advantage of scan
with Vector vertex AI Vector search
so Vector search Okay
um
that's been cool vertex a matching
engine we just changed the name so you
merely know that product so Vector
search is a fully managed Enterprise
grade Vector database that pretty does
one main thing is calculating Vector
similarity very fast
so three key steps to use that that
product so one take your embeddings and
import your embeddings in Vector search
to create an index to Cluster the
embeddings into embedding vectors into
similar entities and three query a live
endpoint with your application to serve
online prediction and get search results
so why using vertex AI Vector search all
right so first it's Enterprise ready
with you know scalability and load
latency again you can perform search of
a billion of embeddings at high
throughoutput with super low latency
so it's a fully managed solution right
that auto scales for example so that you
don't have to worry about managing uh
the infrastructure and you can focus on
building great products that Delight
your customers
and third it's very efficient you know
and basically thanks to the underlying
algorithm as a result it lowers your
total cost of ownership when compared to
other approaches
okay now let's recap everything and see
how we've used vertex AI multimodal
embeddings API and Vector search to
power the demo so the flow really looks
like the following so the first phase is
embed an index so that happens offline
right so you here you pass all your
input data in that case the 5.7 billion
image to the multi-model remitting API
to generate the embedding
then you insert those embeddings in the
vector search database and Trigger the
creation of an index to enable
similarity search and then you go to
live endpoint that you can query
the second phase is online right it's at
the search time so here you pass your
text query so here stylish desk or an
image to the multi-modern emitting and
you get the embedding and you take the
resulting embeddings and send them as a
query to the vector search live endpoint
and finally you get backed ranked result
so here in the form of image that shares
similarities with the text search right
and they happen in different uh they
happen so it's one side is emitting for
text and I'm adding for image but as
they are sharing the same editing space
you can you can you can make a
comparison behind between them
and
um yeah that wraps up the architecture
pattern overview and now Anand will tell
us more about how embeddings are used in
the world of gen AI
thanks Fabian
see at this point you're probably
thinking yeah embeddings are awesome
we're sold but the title of this talk
had the term generative AI in it so we
want to hear more about generative AI
all right let's talk about how
embeddings are used in the world of
generative AI they'll be used in many
creative ways so today we'll just touch
upon the two most popular ways in which
embeddings are used in the world of
generative AI by far the most popular
usage of embeddings is to power this
Paradigm or family of architectures
called retrieval augmented generation
and thank you Eric for teeing it up for
me
um retrieval augmented generation
honestly it's a fancy way of saying
let's find and feed the llm pertinent
context and information at query time
this Paradigm is also often referred to
by the term grounding so you may have
heard the term grounding the element
so before we get into the architecture
let's look at what are the key problems
we're trying to solve the first problem
we're trying to solve is that llms don't
know your business data or your domain
specific data LMS are typically trained
on public content from the internet
but they're not familiar with your data
and your data May matter the most for
your use case
the second problem we're trying to
address is that llms don't have
real-time information they they do
accumulate and encode a lot of
information but that's information up
until the point that they were trained
and they're not accumulating new
information after they're trained so
they may not have information from
yesterday or last week or even last
month
the third problem we're trying to solve
is accurately citing sources of
information
for many Enterprise use cases you want
the llm to give you the answer you're
looking for but also specify what is the
source the original source of that
information
the thing is llms they do encode a lot
of information within their parameters
or weights and that's called parametric
knowledge but when they give reply is
based purely on parametric knowledge
they struggle to cite the source so what
is the solution
the solution is to find and feed the llm
pertinent knowledge or context at query
Time by using an information retrieval
system
so this is the high level architecture
at a high level you start with the input
prompt and in the in the world of
generative AI the word prompt is often
used to refer to the input of the query
that's passed to the model so you start
with the input prompt and before you
give it to the llm you actually call an
information retrieval system that has
indexed the information you want the llm
to use as context you call the
information retrieval system you find
the most relevant matches you take the
content of each match and you append
that to the prompt and you take that
augmented prompt and pass it to the llm
so now the llm has the original query
but also has a whole bunch of additional
information it can use this context to
answer the query
so let's actually take a look at a very
a simple an example of a simple
architecture a simple retrieval
augmented generation architecture that
can be created with the tools we've
discussed so far in this presentation
so step one is to create the index so
you start with the document Corpus or
the knowledge base that you want to
index
and you take the text of these documents
and you call an embeddings API
if the documents are large you may want
to chunk them up into slightly smaller
pieces
now you want to take these embeddings
and you want to put them in an
embeddings plus content Index this
embeddings plus content index consists
of two things one is the vector search
solution which Fabian described in
detail
but here in addition to finding the the
most similar vectors what we want to do
is also return the content associated
with each vector and for that you can
just use your favorite low latency key
Value Store
I do want to call out that the updated
vertex AI feature store now supports
embedding management and retrieval
capabilities so you may want to check
that out please check out AI ml303 for
more details
all right so we have our index now so
what happens at query time at query time
the user query comes in the user prompt
you convert that to an embedding Vector
you look up the embeddings plus content
index you get the top K most relevant
matches you append the content of those
matches to the prompt you pass it to the
llm and the llm response and there you
have it folks that's a simple retrieval
augmented generation architecture
now let's look at the second most
popular use of embeddings in the world
of generative Ai and that is to empower
llms with the with the the capability of
memory
so what is the problem here the problem
is that llms don't have any memory of
their own they get a query they process
the query they return the response each
query is independent for the llm they
don't retain any information about the
query or the response beyond the
duration of the query but there are many
applications particularly assistive chat
applications chat agents and so forth
where you actually want them to remember
what was discussed in you know a while
back in the conversation or even
remember what was discussed in Prior
chat sessions
now I do want to call out that when
you're building a chat application the
most recent turns of the conversation
they are passed back to the llm each
time so the llm has the most recent
context but they actually wanted to
remember you know what was said a while
back or in previous sessions as well
right
so what is the solution
does anyone want to take a guess
the solution is to use embeddings and
Vector search
um so let's let's quickly take a look at
an architecture so you have you have
your long-term memory service
um in the long-term memory service you
use an embeddings API and you use the
embeddings plus content index that we
saw on the previous slide
now you're having a chat session for
each turn of the conversation you take
the prompt you convert it to embeddings
you look up the long-term memory service
to find the most relevant matches you
append it to the prompt you give it to
the model and the model response with
the relevant context now there's one
thing you have to remember here you have
to remember to put back
the most recent prompt and the most
recent response of the model in that
long-term memory service so you have it
as context for Downstream conversations
and again there you have it folks now
but you know it's it's that simple to
empower your llms with long-term memory
all right moving along now let's look at
tuning embedding models and before we
dive into this I'm actually very excited
to call out that the private preview
release of tuning for the vertex AI text
embeddings API is now available
so you know we'd love for you to check
it out now when we talk about embedding
tuning and embedding model let's start
with why you may even want to do that as
you've heard us say multiple times right
now embeddings and code Rich semantic
information and then you do semantic
similarity matching but for your use
case what constitutes semantic
similarity may be different in nuanced
ways
or the the attributes that matter the
most for your use case may be certainly
different from some other use case and
I'll give you an example so when you're
doing semantic similarity matching there
may be a use case where uh all you care
about is the semantics or the meaning of
the words in some piece of text or the
objects in some image
now there may be another use case where
definitely the meaning of the words or
the objects in the image matter but what
also matters perhaps more could be the
style or tone of that content right so
long story short there are different use
cases where different attributes matter
more so how do you tell the model what
are the attributes that matter the most
well you actually do that by giving a
whole bunch of examples to the model
each example and this is the input to
the tuning job each example is a pair of
items
and each pair you specify if the if that
pair of items is a semantically similar
pair for your use case or whether that's
a semantically dissimilar pair for your
use case and then the model learns from
that so let's actually take a look at
how the model learns I want to show a
simple architecture for embedding model
tuning but what I want to call out is
the goal here is to give you an
intuition of what is happening the
actual implementation we use under the
hood for the vertex tuning embeddings
tuning API is actually far more
sophisticated we won't have enough time
to dive into that so I'm just going to
give you the intuition of what happens
when you're doing embedding tuning
so what happens when you use an
embedding generating model you have your
content you pass it through an encoder
you get embeddings but now remember that
when you're doing tuning you provide a
whole bunch of examples and each example
has a pair of items
so for each item in the pair you have
the encoder and you produce embeddings
right
now let's take a similarity function and
produce a similarity score for those
embeddings and a common similarity
function is cosine similarity there are
other similarity functions as well so
you're Computing a similarity score now
for the items in your example that are
semantically similar for your use case
you want that similarity score to be as
high as possible and for the items that
are semantically dissimilar for your use
case you want that similarity score to
be low and that is essentially what
we're doing when we're tuning the model
we're updating the weights of the
encoder the parameters of the encoder
are updated so that the similarity score
is high for the semantically similar
examples and the similarity score is low
for the semantically dissimilar examples
and that's how embedding tuning works
um really cool stuff right and yeah we
would love for you to check it out and
I'll pass things over to Fabian to talk
about how you can get started
um okay so here we are providing a few
pointers to Google Cloud product to help
you create
um use and tune embeddings and finally
if you're looking for more TurnKey
solution out of the out of the box
solution
um that for embeddings based search
product you can check vertex CI Vision
Warehouse which is a fully managed
service to cover your media content
um storage and search needs for example
videos and image and vertex AI search to
serve all your search needs with
Enterprise content such as web page
tablet documents PDF and so on
and for more information you can always
get in touch with us through your Google
Cloud contact
[Applause]
foreign